welcome to glamour unfiltered with me
deborah joseph editor-in-chief and huda
katan
beauty boss extraordinaire founder of
huda beauty and chairwoman
welcome and thank you for joining me
thank you my love so happy to finally
connect
so you are the beauty boss
extraordinaire as far as i'm concerned
i've been following you for quite a long
time
and in fact you were my first cover
store when i became editor-in-chief of
glamour three years ago
and there was a very personal reason for
that i'm also a middle eastern heritage
and i don't remember growing up seeing
anybody who reflected myself back at me
on the cover of a magazine and yeah it
was so important to me that you were my
first cover
um how about you growing up from iraqi
heritage did you find people like
yourself
reflected back at you definitely not
um to be honest there wasn't somebody
you know similar to me but even like
remotely close um you know and i think
that was a that was a big problem
growing up not having representation or
feeling included or feeling like i was a
part of the
the beauty conversation that was that
was something that was a struggle
because i also wanted it so badly you
know i wanted to feel beautiful
so badly and just not being able to to
have anybody
you know represent or or feel included
was it was tough
can i talk a bit about growing up what
what were your perceptions of beauty
growing up in america
as you know with the darker skin and
probably different cultural references
and at home different culture
how was it for you i didn't i didn't
remember
happy childhood memories i don't have
like the happiest i actually feel like
it was a struggle
for especially my early my early teen
years um
i wasn't happy um to be honest like with
myself or you know i felt i was always
inadequate and that that was
that was a hard thing because you know
you don't really realize why you feel
this way you don't realize it may be the
external things that are
maybe painting an incorrect picture of
the way that you're feeling but
you actually internalize it as a child
you feel like oh this is
people are treating me this way or
people are treating me like i'm an
outsider
you know and and i i am arab american
and i grew up in a household who like i
have amazing parents but my extended
family
also made me feel like oh you're too
you're too brown why are you always in
the sun you need to be lighter skinned
and
i love being brown so i i was like i had
this internal conflict in my head i was
like wait
i don't agree with them i just i just
don't and i like no matter what they say
i just won't agree with them
but then i'm also going outside and i
still feel this way and i and i
internally didn't feel like that was
right
you started out in finance before makeup
and
you've obviously created this incredible
company have you still experienced a lot
of sexism
on your way up like wait too much to be
honest
you know before when i when i had when i
was in university a little bit when i
graduated tremendously and when i got
into my
career it was overwhelming with the men
who would not take me seriously like
it's a hobby like you know just
like look let's hand it over to the guys
like let them do the real work
and you know it's funny because one of
my friends actually told me you know
i i become a super alpha female i don't
turn it on all the time
but when i need to be very direct and
tell people like you know
no that's not going to happen i've
learned how to do that and i was talking
to a good friend of mine who's um who is
a male and he
he's a super feminist you know he shared
something he was like you know women who
who have to you know in the similar
positions as men actually become
far more alpha than the guys do and it's
kind of something we're forced to become
like as women we're kind of forced to be
to
to be more firm and navigating that
journey when you're like well i i don't
always want to be that person
is something that i think is a is a is
an interesting dynamic that women are
learning nowadays
but yeah sexism exists and it is
um it's it's oppression uh honestly
that's what it is it's oppression do you
have a response to it when you have it
in your everyday life
when i need to to put a man in place i
try to do it nicely at first
i try to find a way to do it nicely at
first but when i have to be firm
i can be quite direct without without
being um
mean i've learned how to do that that
was a lot i had to learn how to do that
because i would kind of get like a
little bit upset like um excuse me
like i am going to be the one making the
decision look at me
like why are you not making eye contact
with me and now i've learned to just
ignore people sometimes and and um
you know make them then come to me for
the answer did that kind of feed into
your own views of wanting to set up a
business so that you could do it how you
wanted it to be i
i didn't really realize it at the time
now yes
at the time when we were starting the
brand it was more so like you know i
just still
felt like it was filling a void for me
um
and i was i was i definitely felt at the
time it was like i wanted
something different whether that was
products maybe later on down the line a
movement but at the time it was just
more so like i just wanted something
different you know
you think life's changing i mean i know
certainly in my career in my business
things are changing for diversity for
different skin colors it's welcomed it's
encouraged
having different points of view do you
feel the same for you
do you feel you've got more of a voice
now i want to say yes
but i still feel like there's a lot of
work that needs to be done i feel right
now
when people are using things like
inclusivity and vulnerability all these
things it's a tool
i don't actually feel like it's genuine
and you know i've seen ads from big
beauty brands
where they will have like it kind of
upsets me if i'm honest with you
where they will have like a dark skinned
girl trying on the light foundation and
i'm like that's not inclusivity what are
you doing
you know like i don't even understand
what the point of that was you know and
so
it's obvious it's very obvious sometimes
it's more obvious sometimes it's less
obvious
but sometimes it's just a tool of it's
just a tool i'm glad you mentioned
foundation because foundation for me
with beauty has been a massive
conversation in my own head
so i don't wear foundation and there is
a good reason for it i tried
so many times in my late teens and early
20s to find a foundation
and every time i bought one i'd leave
the shop and my skin would be
uh gray um and
right because i'm not so dark skinned
the color was right
but the tone was not a middle eastern
tone it wasn't yellow
it wasn't olive it wasn't right and so
this
only occurred to me about two years ago
why this was
because suddenly people like you are
bringing out wide wide ranges of
foundation colors that do reflect
me and darker skinned women and i've
spoken to them about it and this is a
huge shift in change in our industry
you know what you want to know something
crazy is
so many foundation brands i am the
darkest shade
me too yeah yeah i mean
it's crazy it's like it's ludicrous that
we are the darkest shade when we are
like
you know i think we're on the medium to
we're probably medium you know
i want to say we're like on the on the
light medium but close to more like the
lightning
it's not it's kind of crazy like i've
found so many brands or i buy the
darkest shade and it's like the shade
for me and it's it's still
pink it still makes me look beigey and
ashy and
i you know i realized why too
because um after getting into the
manufacturers like when i was developing
colors with them and i was like i want
it richer i want it deeper i wanted that
that that color that rich you know that
sexy tone
and they were like okay well add black
pigment and i was like wait wait what
are you doing
like no wonder people look gray and they
would literally think to add black
pigment you know
obviously our skin tones are such a mix
of blues and reds and yellows and
goldens and you know so many different
tones
and so i think that there was just
laziness to be honest
um and also it became it was first
laziness and it became
like conditioning and then people didn't
really break the mold and it wasn't
until that point where you say no i want
it i want to change it and
it does require a lot of work it does
require a lot of work but i think um you
know companies will change it and
there's going to be tones for us that
will melt into our skin and make us feel
so beautiful and we'll wear and we'll be
like we don't even feel like we're
wearing anything i do want to talk about
foundation because i'm a big fan of it
but all the reasons we've just discussed
because it's so important
representation in beauty in this way
talk to me through
like launching it and now bringing out a
new version of it talk me through
your process mentally and getting the
shades right and and the product right
we've had some pretty hard projects
honestly we've had you know as
a small beauty brand not having like
access to you know any type of
information or anything other than like
what's out there for public
like for the public knowledge it was a
bit tough and foundation for me was the
toughest because
i wanted to personally shade match every
single person
and i think i made it tough for my ped
team because they were like we did all
the
work we tried it on so many skin tones
then we had the manufacturer we're the
biggest manufacturers in the world
making for so many skin tones shade
match and i was like that's amazing i
want to see it on people's skin
so um you know we we uh shade matched
every single tone and we made sure that
each
each person we found was represented
across the tone and you've reformulated
it now can you talk me through that
oh we reformulated over 40 times um way
over 48 times i think it was
i think it was like more around 50 or
even
more times it was just you know we
wanted to take out some of the
ingredients in there we had d5 which you
know was the greedy that sometimes
irritated people's skin but it was so
amazing at making products like really
homogeneous um you know and
it looked beautiful on the skin but
there was a lot of feedback we got so
much feedback from the industry and the
crazy thing is and i don't think i've
ever shared this with anyone
we were we were constantly tweaking it
we weren't releasing the tweaked version
and then we were like we should we
release the tweaked version and just
like
release it in the market because then we
all have to take back old stock people
can just like
they'll be like oh why is this so much
better but then our retailers are like
this is so much better you guys took out
the fragrance it's like a world of a
difference you need to actually tell
people
why you made it different and it was you
know it was because of everything
everybody was telling us we listened to
everything i wanted to talk about hair
because
for me and i know your hair's not done
but for me my hair jenny has been
one of the most significant beauty
journeys of my life
i have straightened my hair my whole
life i've got naturally curly hair
i've got a scar on my left hand i don't
know if you can see it from where my mom
she burnt my hand with a hair dryer at
age about five
because she wanted to match
westernized beauty standards and again
as a middle eastern woman
it wasn't okay to walk out with curly
hair we all had to have straight western
hair is that a journey you've been
through
yeah i mean there's there's all these
different forms that we use to try to be
included or to try to be
you know um you know quote unquote
acceptable
to society so um hair is here's the one
though when you
mistreat it you you can you can't
reverse it so
you know it's a shame and i you know i
try to post pictures too with curly hair
people just don't
love it so i i usually wear my hair
however
whatever my mood is yeah you love going
into hair products is that something
that we can see from you in the future
you know i want it from you that's why
i'm asking
it's interesting that you asked that
because my team wants to do hair um hair
care but i don't want to do it yet
i really don't just i feel like we
haven't won in skincare yet you know i
feel like we still have so much more to
do in skincare and
you know it's only been a year for
wishful and i want to see like where we
continue to grow i feel like there's so
many areas
in the company that i would like to
focus on so i mean
would you like to go with skincare what
have you not achieved yet when we
launched skincare everybody told us that
we just couldn't do it like all of our
even a lot of our partners were like
it's just you know you have to accept
the fact
that nobody's been successful in makeup
and skincare
from the big brands to the small brands
never nobody's ever been successful
um so that was a challenge that we we
knew we had to face and so
i still feel like you know we we had
great numbers amazing numbers
um you know really successful launches
but i don't think it's enough just yet
like i want to see the life-changing
you know testimonials which we're
getting into but i want to i want to
feel that connection
with a community that's so deep and so
rich that we have with it of beauty
and then i'll feel like you know i
understand it when i feel like we
understand skincare i feel like that we
can go into hair care i know myself i'll
get overwhelmed
do what you're good at make it great
then move on yeah obsess
that's what i like to do i like to
obsess with it and then move on
talk a lot about your own skin journey
what and you mentioned you want to get
those testimonials what do you hope to
achieve from your skin care ranges
wishful
you know i obviously i want people's
skin to become
a version of that they feel really proud
of and that they feel comfortable in
but i also just want like more you know
just skin like acceptance when we did
the campaign
you know i was adamant about not wearing
makeup about not photoshopping and it
was a
really vulnerable moment for me and i
felt extremely exposed extremely
sensitive i felt
super inconfident and i had to go deeper
into that i was like i need to own this
like
i deserve love i really wanted to talk
to you about
um women in the pandemic it has affected
women more than
anybody or certainly more than men but
it's encouraged women
to leave the industry to stop working
we've been sent back to the 1950s with
the housework and the child care
i know you work with mainly women in
your business how have you found it
and how we've been protecting and
supporting them
because i know it's been really
important to you honestly the pandemic
you know it has been one of the most
challenging things um that we've all
gone through because nobody was
expecting it
you know there is so many things that
you know you can kind of
like the economy crashing that's
happened before we're kind of
kind of you know we know how to to
navigate through those situations now
you know even like crazy outbursts
within the government you know we have
we had some crazy leaders sometimes
you're you used to like
you know you kind of block it out
sometimes you can't you know but
things you know that are that are so
overwhelming like a pandemic
and and seeing situations where
businesses are closing
and and it's just like people are dying
people are losing their family members
and
it's very very scary and for me the most
important thing that i wanted to do
at that point was to protect my team and
how have you found it i mean you're a
mother
you're a multi-million pound business so
now how have you found it have you found
the juggle
are you home schooling
she's homeschooling it's never easy
especially like i um
you know i i now have lunch with her and
i try to make sure i have the mornings
with her and then i i have to kind of
end my day on time thank you
so much it's been an absolute pleasure
and a joy i'm a huge admirer of
everything you do
and i can't wait to see what you do next
thank you my love you're so sweet and
i'm so glad i got to connect